[Music]
dear
inse we meet again don't try to flirt
with
me cuz you're not really my friend but
you take up half this bed living rentree
in my head all in
[Music]
security show up in my mirr point out
the worst in
me you whisper in my ear that my lips
are way too thin too many miles on my
skin if I can't find a way to get you
gone can we find a way to get along
along careless and you cruel and oh you
mind maybe you could try a little
kindness instead hurt
me
in this time Feels Like Love she's
really sure
me so please don't mess this up if you
cut in on this St I may it never get
another
chance I'll never find a way to get
you wish I could find a way to know
you're
you're careless and you're cruel and all
your
[Music]
mind mayy you could try a little
kindness still Hur instead of hurting me
why you hurting
me
[Music]
inity best songwriter of Our Generation
give it
up all right all right welcome to the
color show everybody give it up for my
band y'all and my wonderful
extraordinary web partner Brandy
Clark that was her single dear and
security off her new self-titled album
Grammy
nominated she recorded it with Brandy
Carlo it's Brandy squared event um I am
so honored she let me sing on it with
her I'm a huge fan all I do is word
vomit every time I'm around her because
I'm such a fan but I literally think
that you are the greatest songwriter of
Our Generation you're so talented
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home